alain gautier bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france on le
disait le rwanda va donc ouvrir son
principal poste frontière avec l'ouganda
rappelez-nous pour quelles raisons
était-il fermé depuis trois ans
on vous savez tout d'abord je tiens à
vous dire je ne suis pas un spécialiste
de géopolitique
donc mon avis est tout à fait je dirais
personnel
le conflit entre l'ouganda et le rwanda
est ancien
depuis que le fpr a quitté l'ouganda
1990 pour venir au rwanda et bien des
relations sont compliquées entre les
deux pays appelés je pense que
le le fpr sais que j'en pense 'suite à
la
suite de la visite du fils de nos cv ni
et bien on ne peut que se réjouir de
l'ouverture de cette frontière
et pourquoi donc ces relations qu est ce
qui faisait que c'était ses relations
étaient particulièrement tendues ces
dernières années alors qu'auparavant les
deux pays étaient plutôt des proches
alliés
écoutez ça ce sont des questions je
dirais d'ordre politique le président
c'est venez a pris des positions
qu'ils n'étaient pas conformes à celles
que le rwanda attendait il faut aussi
situé 7
se confie dans le cadre de de la guerre
qui existent de vauban beau en plus
démocratique du congo depuis 1994 vous
savez que lorsque les génocidaires ont
fui le pays et bien tout le nord et le
sud qui se sont enflammés et jusqu'à ce
jour et on vous regrettez en particulier
que la monusco qui est présente là bas
depuis ce temps là ne fasse pratiquement
rien donc quand on évoque les relations
entre l'ouganda et le renard il faut les
situer dans ce cadre de la région des
grands lacs et pourquoi aujourd'hui on
assiste à ce dégel entre les deux pays
qui en sont les acteurs
alors les habitants je vous dis ce sont
le fils de mousser les lits qui a fait
récemment une visite au président kagame
il est absolument essentiel pour la
sécurité pour la paix dans la région des
grands lacs que tous ces pays qui font
partie de cette région puissent
vivre dans des relations qui
redeviennent normales à la fois pour des
raisons politiques bien évidemment mais
aussi pour des raisons économiques on il
faut savoir que de nombreux produits
de première nécessité passent les
frontières normalement entre l'ouganda
et le rwanda il y avait donc urgence de
enfin rétablir de bonnes relations je
pense qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire mais c'est un premier
pas dont on doit se féliciter justement
quelles conséquences pour la région à
cette normalisation des relations entre
le rwanda et l'ouganda à vous ne parliez
un de l'aspect économique qui en a
d'autres
avec l'aspect économique et donnent des
éléments bien évidemment mais il faut il
ne faut pas oublier l'aspect politique
dans la région des grands lacs vous avez
quatre grands pays le la république
démocratique du congo l'ouganda le
burundi et la tanzanie
en plus bien sûr du mandat qui est au
milieu et si l'on veut que deux régions
la ville dans l'appel je dirais même
dans la prospérité il est indispensable
que ces cinq pays là puissent avoir des
relations
cordiales donc je crois que le bénéfice
essentiel c'est un bénéfice d'ordre
politique pour la paix et la prospérité
de la région parce qu'effectivement le
le rwanda lui accusé son voisin
l'ouganda de persécuter ses
ressortissants l'ouganda accuse elle le
rwanda d'espionnage est ce que chacune
des parties s'est engagé à des actes
pour concrétiser cette normalisation
alors là vous me posez une question à
laquelle je ne veux pas répond je ne
suis pas un proche des ses différents
gouvernements
je ne suis qu'un citoyen franco rwandais
qui vient de temps en temps au rwanda
mais dans un but unique celui de
rechercher des témoins dans le cadre de
notre combat pour la justice donc
dans la poursuite des génocidaires qui
sont en france donc la question que vous
me posez dépasse les compétences en tout
cas comment est-ce que cette annonce a
été perçue au rwanda précisément
alors je dois vous avouer que je n'en ai
pas beaucoup entendu parler
elles concernent essentiellement le nom
de politique il va falloir attendre
quelques jours quelques semaines pour
voir quelles conséquences le bambin on
va pouvoir tirer de cette décision je
dirais que c'est un petit pas en avant
un pas en avant pour
mieux vivre ensemble
ce qui est une condition essentielle je
le répète pour la paix dans cette région
des grands lacs merci beaucoup alain
gautier pour votre éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france je rappelle vous êtes co
fondateur de collectif des parties
civiles pour le rwanda